...
-Emanuele Coccia,
nous traversons une crise majeure,
aux multiples facettes,
mais qui est avant tout climatique.
Quel rôle le philosophe
peut-il jouer ?
-Bah, la philosophie
a un rôle majeur,
parce que si on peut résoudre
ce souci, cette crise,
c'est parce qu'on est arrivés
à aimer le monde, ce monde,
la Terre, la planète,
de manière obsessionnelle,
jusqu'à vouloir en sauver
la moindre particule.
-Vous pensez qu'il y a
une philosophie
de la crise qui serait spécifique
au moment que nous vivons ?
Est-ce que la crise
contraint ou convoque
un nouveau type
de philosophie ?
-Je sais pas s'il y a
une philosophie à la crise,
ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'on a vécu,
et pas juste à cause
de la crise climatique,
un moment,
disons un demi-siècle
de transformations radicales
comme peut-être
à peine l'humanité entière
en a traversé,
au sens qu'il y a
une révolution technologique
qui a été incroyable,
moi, je fais partie de personnes
qui ont vécu la transition
entre le moment
où il fallait aller
en bibliothèque pour chercher
des savoirs et le moment
où la totalité des savoirs
est dans ta poche,
littéralement dans ta poche.
Il y a eu une transformation
géopolitique monstrueuse,
en fait, qui fait que, voilà,
l'axe du pouvoir sur la planète,
comment dire, s'est déplacé en Asie,
et il y a eu ce changement
climatique majeur.
Et cet ensemble de changements
fait que, au fond,
c'est comme si on n'habitait pas
la même planète que nos parents,
comme si l'humanité entière
avait été déplacée
sur une autre planète et donc,
c'est comme si chacun de nous
était un peu
dans la même position
d'Adam et Eve,
qui sont obligés de nommer
les choses qu'ils voient
pour la première fois.
Et c'est une, comment dire,
c'est une posture
à la fois enivrante,
parce que nommer les choses,
découvrir les choses,
poser sur la réalité
le tout premier regard,
ça a quelque chose de sublime,
mais aussi dangereux,
parce qu'on connaît pas,
donc on risque
chaque instant
de se brûler la peau,
de se faire mal, de mourir, etc.
Donc il n'y a pas, peut-être,
une philosophie de la crise
mais c'est sûr que notre situation
est incomparable
et c'est sûr qu'on est appelés
à réimaginer,
à reconfigurer,
à produire des nouveaux savoirs
sur le monde, en fait.
-Je vais vous faire réagir
à un propos de Michel Foucault,
qui justement définit la philosophie
en disant qu'il n'y en a plus.
On va l'écouter,
c'était en 1966.
*-Il est très difficile
de définir
ce qu'est actuellement
la philosophie.
Il me semble que, maintenant,
la philosophie est en train
de disparaître.
Quand je dis qu'elle disparaît,
je ne veux pas dire
que nous arrivons
à un âge où, finalement,
tout le savoir
devient positif mais je crois
que la philosophie
se dissout et se dissipe
dans toute
une série d'activités de pensée
dont il est difficile de dire
si elles sont proprement
scientifiques ou proprement
philosophiques.
Nous arrivons à un âge
qui est peut-être celui
de la pensée pure,
de la pensée en acte
et, après tout,
une discipline aussi abstraite
et générale que la linguistique,
une discipline aussi
fondamentale que la logique,
une activité comme la littérature,
depuis Joyce, par exemple,
eh bien toutes ces activités
sont probablement des activités
de pensée
et elles tiennent lieu
de philosophie,
non pas qu'elles prennent la place
de la philosophie mais,
en quelque sorte,
elles sont le déploiement
même de ce qu'était autrefois
la philosophie.
-Pas mal, hein,
ce qu'on entendait
à la télévision en 66 ?
-Tout à fait.
-A une heure de grande écoute !
-Non, je suis d'accord,
même, je serais tenté
de radicaliser son propos
au sens que, au fond,
la philosophie a toujours
été dissipée,
dissolue.
Je répète, au fond,
si on s'épanche
sur les canons
de la philosophie,
ce qu'on est censés enseigner
par exemple aux élèves au lycée
ou à la fac,
Foucault parlait de Joyce,
mais Platon a produit des oeuvres
techniquement littéraires,
Lucrèce a écrit un poème
qu'on étudie aussi
dans les études de littérature,
etc., etc.
Au fond, la littérature n'a jamais
été une discipline spécifique,
même pas au Moyen Age, au fond,
la philosophie était
comme indissociable
de la théologie,
qui est une science très bizarre
et très différente.
Et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui,
c'est peut-être
qu'on trouve
de la pensée philosophique,
comme dit Foucault,
un peu partout,
surtout par exemple
dans les arts.
On a fait de l'art une discipline
de la pensée où chaque artiste
doit tout d'abord réinventer
le médium nécessaire
pour exprimer une idée.
D'une certaine manière,
l'art contemporain
est devenu une sorte
de forme paradigmatique
de la pensée
où on est obligé tout d'abord
de s'interroger
sur les conditions de possibilités
d'expression d'une idée.
Ce qui est très important,
parce que la prise de conscience
qui a lieu aujourd'hui
est qu'on n'est pas obligé d'écrire
pour penser ou pour faire
de la philosophie.
-Qui n'est plus à l'université
mais dans de nouvelles
pratiques de création.
-La philosophie se fait
très rarement à l'université,
dans le sens où, si on regarde,
au cours de l'histoire,
ça s'est passé que dans des moments
spécifiques, un peu au Moyen Age,
et même, parce que c'était pas
dans les facs de philosophie
mais surtout de théologie,
et un peu à l'âge moderne,
mais pour une très courte durée.
Dans l'histoire
de ce qu'on appelle philosophie,
la pensée s'exerce un peu partout,
même en marchant,
même, je sais pas,
en faisant la vaisselle,
donc l'université,
ce n'est pas le lieu,
en plus par définition,
qui doit produire la philosophie,
c'est le lieu qui est censé,
à la limite, la transmettre.
L'université est le lieu
où on se penche
sur ce qui s'est passé
il y a un demi-siècle,
ou bien il y a
plusieurs siècles.
-L'histoire de la philosophie.
-Ou l'histoire de n'importe quoi,
alors qu'il y a par exemple
une inversion intéressante :
les musées qui étaient
une institution tournée le passé
sont devenus un laboratoire
de divination du futur,
à tel point qu'on va voir
une expo d'art contemporain,
justement, aussi et surtout
pour deviner le futur
plutôt que pour comprendre
le présent ou le passé.
Il faut, si on veut vraiment
retransformer à nouveau
ou faire des universités
un lieu d'élaboration du futur,
il faut leur donner
cette liberté de brasser
n'importe quel aspect
de l'existence humaine,
et pas que humaine,
d'ailleurs,
et d'utiliser
n'importe quel médium.
J'aurais du mal
à dire ce que c'est
la philosophie
dans le sens que, au fond,
si on se penche sur l'ensemble
de livres ou de personnes
qu'on est censés considérer
comme des philosophes,
cet ensemble réunit
des gens, des livres,
des sujets totalement disparates,
qui n'ont pas,
qui n'ont aucune unité
dans la méthode,
dans l'objet, dans le style.
Il y a des livres qui ressemblent
à des oeuvres littéraires,
il y a des livres
qui ressemblent à des oeuvres,
à des traités d'économie,
il y a des poèmes,
il y a des tags qui sont
des oeuvres philosophiques et,
au fond, la seule manière
de définir la philosophie serait
de revenir aux deux concepts
contenus dans son nom,
son nom grec,
qui est l'amour
et le savoir, donc au fond,
les philosophes, ce sont des...
des aimants,
des amateurs de force
de la connaissance,
mais qui sont alimentés
et nourris que
par cette passion aveugle
et obsessionnelle, en fait.
Ce qui veut dire, au fond,
pour le traduire,
que la philosophie est partout,
n'est pas un savoir
parmi les autres,
mais c'est une intensité
qui traverse n'importe quel savoir,
n'importe quelle discipline.
-Alors vous, vous pratiquez
ce genre de philosophie,
vos essais sont assez hybrides,
à la fois poétiques,
philosophiques.
Est-ce parce que vous avez,
finalement, une formation
tout à fait singulière, différente,
par rapport à un professeur
de philosophie ?
Puisque vous avez commencé
vos études dans un lycée agricole.
-J'ai été envoyé, oui,
dans un lycée,
dans un lycée agricole
par un geste féministe
inconscient de ma mère,
qui a envoyé ma soeur aînée
au lycée classique,
donc là où on apprend
le grec, le latin,
et moi et mon frère,
ma mère nous a dit
qu'il fallait apprendre
un métier, donc...
C'était une stratégie efficace
parce que, justement,
pour démontrer à ma mère
que je pouvais faire l'université,
je suis devenu même
prof à la fac.
Je me suis retrouvé
dans cet endroit
qui était, à l'époque,
un endroit d'exclusion
de toute forme de mondanité
ou de société,
mais qui m'a fait
énormément de bien,
pour deux raisons, tout d'abord
parce que, au fond,
le sous-entendu était
que le premier objet du savoir
ou de l'effort de connaissance,
ce sont les plantes
et donc les non-humains,
le monde lui-même et pas l'humain,
donc ça m'a appris
à comprendre que si on doit
s'efforcer à produire
de la connaissance,
c'est parce que le monde
est plus important
que nous-mêmes
et, après, parce que
ce lycée m'a mis dans une posture
ou dans une position
à la fois d'outsider
et de philosophe,
c'est-à-dire, au fond,
j'étais obligé
d'apprendre tout
ce que je voulais apprendre
par une volonté,
par une passion personnelle,
et pas forcément
en passant par un maître,
par une école, par une discipline,
par une méthode, etc.
-Alors, ça a donné
un très beau livre
qui s'intitule
"La vie des plantes",
celui qui vous a fait
connaître du grand public
et dans lequel, effectivement,
vous travaillez sur le rôle
absolument fondamental
de la plante,
qui crée le monde,
en quelque sorte, qui fait monde,
vous privilégiez
la vie sensible à la vie
intelligible.
On peut revenir un petit peu
sur cette vie des plantes et,
question subsidiaire :
en quoi, de ce fait, le philosophe
a quelque chose de plus à dire
que par exemple le botaniste
ou le chercheur en sciences
de la nature ?
-Ce que j'ai essayé de faire,
c'est tirer les dernières
conséquences de ce qu'on peut
trouver dans tout
manuel de botanique,
au fond,
l'une des premières phrases
qu'on trouvera dans n'importe
quel manuel de botanique,
peu importe le niveau,
c'est que les plantes,
grâce à la photosynthèse,
modifient la teneur
en oxygène de l'atmosphère,
donc modifient l'atmosphère
terrestre, planétaire,
et modifient évidemment
les sols, etc.,
mais modifient aussi
la présence
de l'énergie sur Terre.
Donc première conséquence qu'on peut
tirer de ce fait élémentaire,
c'est que le monde,
tel qu'on le connaît,
a été littéralement produit
par les plantes, en fait,
qui permettent
à la Terre de devenir
un espace respirable
et qui surtout mettent
à disposition des animaux
une quantité inouïe d'énergie.
Au fond, les plantes capturent
l'énergie solaire,
et on l'oublie,
mais l'énergie solaire,
c'est un élément extraterrestre,
ce qui fait que notre vie,
où que nous soyons,
et les plantes
d'ailleurs elles-mêmes,
fait de nous des aliens,
un peu, des extraterrestres.
On a un squelette terrestre
et une vie qui est
alimentée par une source
d'énergie extraterrestre.
C'est intéressant,
il capture l'énergie
solaire, comment dire,
il l'insuffle
dans la chair minérale
de la planète.
Ce qui fait que, au fond,
à chaque fois,
ça sonne un peu bizarre,
mais chaque fois qu'on mange,
on est en train
de chercher cette énergie
cachée dans le corps des autres,
ce qui fait de la nutrition,
au fond, cette quête presque
spirituelle de lumière
et ce commerce
de lumière qui passe
de corps à corps,
d'espèce en espèce.
Mais la deuxième conséquence
est encore plus intéressante :
les plantes nous enseignent
deux choses,
tout d'abord que le monde
est un espace
fabriqué et pas naturel.
En fait, la Terre a
été rendue habitable,
vivable par les vivants eux-mêmes,
qui l'ont ciselée
depuis des milliards d'années,
qui l'ont transformée,
donc la Terre,
au fond, c'est un artefact
qui n'est pas
moins artificiel
que notre smartphone.
Elle est au fond beaucoup
plus artificielle
parce qu'elle a été produite
par des milliards
de générations
de milliards de vivants.
C'est comme si c'était
une énorme oeuvre collective
et c'est pour ça qu'elle est
si vulnérable et si fragile,
car elle a été produite
par plein de gens.
La deuxième conséquence
de ce fait élémentaire
qu'est la photosynthèse,
c'est que ce n'est pas vrai
qu'un vivant s'adapte
à l'environnement,
le vivant est obligé, pour vivre,
de modifier radicalement
l'espace qui l'entoure,
les autres vivants qui sont
à côté de lui, etc.
L'environnement,
c'est pas quelque chose qui est là
et auquel on doit se plier,
n'importe quel vivant transforme
de manière extrêmement
imprévisible et créative
l'espace qui l'entoure,
c'est-à-dire la Terre.
-Vous récusez le terme d'écologie.
-Je le récuse parce que
c'est un terme
qui a été introduit par,
au fond...
Comment dire ?
Le terme écologie a été inventé
par un biologiste allemand
du 19e siècle, Ernst Haeckel,
mais qui modifiait un nom
qui était à l'origine
celui d'économie animale.
C'est une science qui surgit
parce qu'on se rend compte que,
pour comprendre la relation
entre un kangourou et un moustique,
il faut des concepts qui sont
de nature sociologique
et pas de nature chimique,
biologique, physique ou autres.
Le problème, c'est que,
à cette époque-là,
comme on était encore
dans un contexte fixiste,
un contexte où on croyait
que les espèces
étaient les mêmes depuis l'origine
du monde jusqu'à la fin,
et donc si on se penchait
sur la question :
quel est le rapport
entre un kangourou à Sydney,
un moustique à Paris
et un cheval
en Arizona,
comme c'est trois êtres
qui n'avaient aucun
rapport de parenté,
et qui ne se rencontraient
pas dans leur vie,
la seule manière de comprendre
quelle était leur relation,
c'était se mettre du point de vue
de celui qui les avait créés,
c'est-à-dire
les dieux chrétiens.
Or, le problème,
c'est que si tu observes
la Terre,
soit l'ensemble des espaces
et l'ensemble des êtres
du point de vue du dieu,
ce spectacle va se présenter
à toi exactement
comme une grande maison se présente
face au père de famille, en fait,
à celui qui a tout créé
et qui possède tout.
C'est pour ça que l'écologie a été
baptisée économie animale,
l'économie au sens
ancien du terme,
soit la science de la maison,
de l'ordre domestique.
A cette époque-là,
c'est une métaphore et,
comment dire,
un cadre épistémologique
qui permettait à la fois
d'affirmer cette...
qu'il y avait une relation
entre tous les êtres
et tous les espaces,
et un ordre,
mais c'est une métaphore,
une image, un concept
qui a un prix énorme,
pourquoi ?
Tout d'abord, on vient de passer
deux ans confinés à la maison,
donc supposer que le monde
entier est une maison
d'où on ne peut pas sortir signifie,
comment dire, obliger la nature
à être dans un état
de confinement perpétuel,
ce qui est pas très joyeux,
d'une certaine manière.
Et de l'autre côté,
avoir choisi ce modèle domestique
nous a empêchés par exemple
et empêche encore aujourd'hui
l'écologie de penser que
les rapports entre les êtres
puissent être d'ordre politique
et pas domestique, en fait,
qu'il y ait une forme,
la même forme de liberté
qu'il y a entre les humains
lorsqu'ils sortent de leur maison
et la même capacité d'être,
non pas de transgresser un ordre,
mais d'être totalement
indifférent à l'ordre,
alors qu'il règne dans nos maisons,
par exemple,
cette indifférence à l'ordre
dont on fait l'expérience
à chaque fois qu'on sort,
on n'a plus de programme,
on est libre,
on peut se consacrer
aux plaisirs
les plus déchaînés, etc.
C'est pour ça que l'écologie
doit peut-être revenir
sur son histoire
et repenser la source
de cette unité,
la raison pour laquelle
tous ces êtres sont reliés
les uns aux autres à travers
une image, un concept,
une métaphore qui n'est pas
celle de la maison.
-Je précise
que vous avez écrit
un livre sur la maison,
"Une philosophie de la maison",
vous remettez en cause
cette dichotomie entre intérieur
et extérieur en permanence,
ce qui est logique
puisque vous êtes aussi
le philosophe de la métamorphose,
tout est dans tout,
tout se transforme en permanence.
Autre expérience fondatrice
dans votre rapport au monde,
c'est celle de la gémellité.
Vous arrivez à une phrase
tout à fait paradoxale
qui est l'idée que la gémellité
est ce qu'il y a
de plus universel au monde
alors que de prime abord,
de façon intuitive,
on a plutôt l'impression
que c'est extrêmement singulier,
plutôt exceptionnel.
Alors comment vous pouvez
transformer ce qui
semblerait exceptionnel
en quelque chose
au contraire d'universel ?
-L'expérience
de la gémellité est
quelque chose
de très curieux qui est
cette...
Moi, j'ai,
comment dire,
j'ai compris ce que ça veut
dire être jumeau
face à une image
qui trône un peu chez...
dans l'appartement de ma mère,
il y a plein, plein d'images
de moi et mon frère
lorsqu'on était tout jeunes,
tout petits, et les images
de cet âge sont pour moi
très difficiles parce que j'arrive
pas à comprendre qui est qui.
C'est un trouble de l'acte
de reconnaissance de soi
mais c'est un trouble
qui est un trouble d'excès,
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
que j'arrive pas à me reconnaître,
je me reconnais simultanément
dans deux corps,
c'est comme si je disais :
c'est moi deux fois.
Et si on y pense,
cette capacité de se reconnaître
dans n'importe
quelle forme du monde,
c'est quelque chose
qui nous arrive très souvent.
L'acte d'amour est aussi
quelque chose de ce type-là,
même s'il y a aussi au même moment
une force qui nous repousse.
Mais faire l'expérience
de la gémellité,
c'est ça,
c'est avoir en face de toi
quelqu'un qui a ta même forme
et donc ne pas savoir
si c'est toi qui as copié
l'autre, le monde,
ou si c'est le monde
qui t'a copié.
Et cet étrange rapport,
presque mimétique,
où on sait pas qui a commencé
à copier l'autre,
c'est aussi quelque chose
que nous traversons tout le temps.
Penser, c'est faire
cette expérience,
c'est se mettre dans un rapport
mental de gémellité au monde,
c'est de dire :
là, je suis en train de dire,
de nommer quelque chose
et de faire en sorte
que je ne sache pas
si c'est l'élément qui a
copié ma parole ou l'inverse.
Percevoir
est aussi quelque chose
de ce type.
La gémellité n'est pas
quelque chose d'exceptionnel,
c'est juste le fait
que notre rapport aux autres humains
devient ou prend les mêmes formes
que notre rapport au monde,
de manière quotidienne.
C'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit qu'au fond
c'est une expérience
beaucoup plus universelle
que ce que l'on imagine.
Et c'est pour ça peut-être
qu'il faudrait reconnaître
la radicalité et l'universalité
de cette expérience,
parce que reconnaître que tous
sont nos jumeaux nous permettrait
par exemple de dépasser
des questions qui, peut-être,
aujourd'hui,
nous bloquent excessivement,
comme la question de l'identité,
la question par exemple
de l'appartenance à une nation
ou à l'autre, etc.
Au fond, on est tous et toutes
des jumeaux et des jumelles
qui habitons une seule planète,
c'est-à-dire, et ça,
c'est peut-être la prise
de conscience la plus nécessaire,
vu qu'on parle
de crise climatique,
chacun et chacune de nous
est littéralement
un jumeau
et une jumelle de Gaïa.
Au fond, on n'y réfléchit pas,
mais nous sommes faits
de la même chair que la planète,
nous sommes la planète elle-même
qui, en nous,
a décidé d'avoir un autre visage
et de se regarder elle-même
avec des yeux un peu différents.
Et c'est à partir peut-être
de cette reconnaissance
qu'on pourra fonder
différemment l'écologie
et inventer un nouveau
rapport au monde.
-Je vais vous poser quelques
questions du tac-au-tac.
Quel est le rôle
du philosophe dans la cité ?
Il est roi, ermite
ou conseiller du prince ?
-Il est surtout artiste,
en fait, il doit
tout d'abord inventer
des rapports de liberté
dans le corps-à-corps
avec la matière du monde,
un grand artiste, c'est ça,
c'est quelqu'un qui,
même en manipulant du marbre,
arrive à exprimer
sa propre liberté
et à faire
de cette liberté exprimée
les fondements
de la liberté des autres.
Et, surtout,
les grands artistes inventent
et nous ouvrent une vie qui n'était
pas imaginable auparavant.
S'il y a une tâche publique
du philosophe, c'est ça.
-Les trois livres de philosophie
qui vous ont construit ?
-"L'éthique" de Spinoza,
et vu tout
ce que j'ai dit avant,
je dirais que les oeuvres
philosophiques
qui me marquent, bon,
ça change souvent,
parce que je continue à lire,
à étudier,
donc c'est tous les trois mois
que je suis
complètement bouleversé
par quelque chose,
et si je dois ajouter
deux oeuvres
qui me marquent en ce moment,
c'est la collection de 2018
que Alessandro Michele
a designée,
a dessinée pour Gucci,
qui était l'une des oeuvres
philosophiques
les plus intéressantes
du monde contemporain,
et une oeuvre
de Philippe Parreno
qui s'appelle Anywhere,
qui est une étrange oeuvre
où l'oeuvre se présente
comme un personnage de fiction
face à l'artiste, en fait.
-Un livre de littérature ?
-"Les boutiques de cannelle"
de Bruno Schulz.
-Le rôle de la transmission ?
-Le rôle de la transmission,
on vit dans un monde
où tout peut être transmis
immédiatement
et tout existe en tant
qu'il est capable de circuler.
Les réseaux sociaux sont ça.
Donc je crois qu'on ne doit pas
se soucier de la transmission
et d'ailleurs,
le gros problème de l'université,
c'est qu'elle n'a pas compris
que la transmission
se fait ailleurs et qu'il y a
des formes de transmission
qui la dépassent énormément.
Ce qui est important,
c'est de retrouver
le rôle de l'invention
et de l'imagination.
Je crois qu'on est
dans une crise climatique
mais aussi
une crise de l'imagination,
on a du mal à imaginer
le présent et surtout le futur,
on est comme castrés,
on a une peur monstrueuse
d'imaginer un futur possible.
Donc il faut surtout
revenir à l'imagination
plus qu'à la transmission,
qui se fait de manière mécanique
et de manière industrielle.
Donc il faut surtout pas
se soucier de la façon
dont les savoirs sont transmis,
et voilà,
et peuvent circuler.
-Aujourd'hui,
quelle est la grande
question philosophique ?
-Justement, inventer de nouvelles
questions philosophiques.
On vit dans un monde qui n'est
plus celui de nos parents
ou grands-parents,
on est des Adam et Eve,
donc la grande question,
c'est de se poser
de nouvelles questions,
c'est-à-dire : qu'est-ce que c'est,
la réalité en face de nos yeux ?
Parce qu'on n'a pas les mots,
les concepts,
l'expérience de ce monde.
Donc il faut se jeter,
se faire mal,
s'éplucher les genoux
et essayer de comprendre
tout ce qui nous arrive.
-Merci, Emanuele Coccia.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...